if you were to criticize her it seems
like you could do it on merit right it's
just fairly obvious she uses a lot of
words but she's never really saying
anything she's confused she does the
awful laugh all the time when she
doesn't know what to say
but of course what this would lead us to
believe in 2022 is that if you criticize
her you're racist because that's exactly
what happened
on the
morning show called the view take a look
and i don't know that it's about her
laughing because i agree i think that
would be very inappropriate and that's
something that they do to women i think
that she has gone on multiple occasions
a little bit underprepared with with
some of the questions that she's been
asked lester holt asked her a pretty
basic question that she couldn't answer
so i don't know if it's a staff thing
she's not prepared enough perhaps she's
not expecting the questions i don't know
what it is but i think that's the issues
this is like the fourth or fifth time
what it is is that they constantly
question the qualifications of black
women and that's why people are saying
that she's unprepared oh i disagree i
think you can disagree but that's the
truth of it and so this is based in
racism this is based in misogyny and
we're talking about a woman that has
extensive experience abroad extensive
experience as an attorney expensive
extensive experience as
the chief legal officer of one of our
largest states in the country and i i
think this is just much ado about
nothing i mean we didn't talk about vice
president pence's the wright didn't talk
about his handling of the covet epidemic
which i think or the aids epidemic which
i think led to you know thousands and
thousands of deaths and what we what
they're talking about is is her laugh
she was there
um as an emissary really and she wanted
to reassure the nato allies that
that as russia steps up its attacks on
ukraine that the united states was going
to be supportive in fact she's in i
think bulgaria right now she is prepared
she is seasoned
abroad she gets wonderful marks across
the board but this is just something
that i think happens to women and
especially black women
all right sonny hostin we're gonna have
to talk about you for a moment and i
understand that you are a black woman
but that has nothing to do with why i'm
about to criticize you which in your
world means that i'm racist but in
reality no that's just not the truth and
until the rest of us stop playing this
stupid game i know you're going to keep
encroaching on us first off let me just
one comment that she said that made
literally no sense was that mike pence
uh his response having something to do
with the aids crisis the aids crisis was
basically in new york and san francisco
in the mid early to late 80s
mike pence was vice president about
three years ago so i'm a little confused
he also is from indiana
i don't know what you mean by that um
but if you were to criticize his covid
policy
as vice president that would be just
fine and by the way plenty of people did
and it had nothing to do with them
criticizing him because he's a white man
or he's not a black woman or something
like that um the woman who spoke first
there who made uh i thought several
salient points with stephanie grisham i
think she's a guest host because they
can't find a decent conservative woman
who wants to sit on a panel with four
liberal maniacs and be yelled at and
dismissed the way sunny hostin just
dismissed stephanie stephanie's point
was not to overtly
and and sort of over the top criticize
kamala she said maybe she's
underprepared maybe her staff isn't
giving her the right information
etcetera etcetera like she actually was
quite measured in her criticism and then
sonny just to be nope nope it's because
she's a black woman it's because she's a
black woman and it's like it has nothing
to do with that it has nothing to do
with that and i really really mean this
we have to stop playing this game
because it is it is dragging us into
hell that is what it's doing that if you
legitimately criticize someone if
immediately
the other side is able to look at
whatever their intersectional
oppressions perceived oppressions are
and say no it's because they're black no
it's because they're gay no it's because
they're trans no it's because they're
muslim we got a major problem on our
hands because we will only be governed
by backwards idiots and maybe that's
exactly where we're at right now